hello everybody hope they are good what
a day yesterday
what a day I think I stayed in front of
my laptop for 10 hours or so but it was
worth it because I got plenty of action
in the church
um or protection in the one or time
frame yesterday played out we were
talking about the idea that this was a
double information here okay then you
got the retricia that also matched with
the 50ma in the photo in the water time
frame sorry on the mid-range okay that's
your continuation we were talking that
this was a good area to go in long okay
and the targets were the range water
here okay then you also got another rate
receive if you notice and continuation
continuation where to well to the four
hour
time framework that we were talking
about
for qual on time and talking about this
week over here
okay you can see Highgate fully filled
and also the last Target that we had I
was a deviation above the range highs
okay uh because we saw a lot of
liquidity at 31 700 and 31 800 and if
you notice the top of this move
it was a 31 804 okay so you can see the
market maker can be quite you know
accurate now
what do I see in the charts
um okay it's quite difficult question
and I know that
many of you want to hear my answer but I
think once that you hear my answer you
probably regret
um I don't like it I don't like it yet
okay I don't like many things I'll tell
you why I don't like I don't like how
overly aophthoric
crypto treated on YouTube is at the
moment by the way those guys are not
Traders like
um I think there were not many traders
in crypto Twitter and on YouTube okay
most of them are just influencers well
you know the the environment it's very
euphoric okay very polish and if you
notice here
it's playing out if I ignore all the
noise I will tell you what I've been
talking about for quite some time a week
or two is playing out that it's a
deviation above the range size take out
the liquidity fill that week okay and
then get back into the range consolidate
under the range highs and then maybe you
can see a drop
okay
um could it pay out
uh I mean why not you know this is the
this looks like a deviation to me at the
moment so also in the one in the daily
time frame sorry
a crypto 237 for some reason at least in
my feed I can see people saying that the
daily candle is bullish uh I don't think
the same guys and I'm telling you I'm
here trying to be as unbiased and
neutral as possible okay because the
same as I was telling you that we're
gonna see a big move up from here and it
happened and the Bears didn't believe
that now I'm telling you are done like
this and the Bulls are probably giving a
dislike to this video now
um but I'll just tell you what I see in
the charts okay so I'll tell you what I
don't think of this thunderstick in the
daily timeframe is bullish okay uh you
can see here in this one over here all
these weeks to the upside okay but they
didn't manage to break up of this Zone
okay
uh I don't know I think maybe blue okay
check out the all these weeks here okay
a lot of weeks here price you know
multiple times attempt to break out of
this Zone but they couldn't okay
yesterday if you check the the daily
candle close
if you extend it it's the same okay they
couldn't break up of this zone so you
know we saw a very fast move oh but
still liquid and breakup of this Zone
and he also left unequality pool behind
Okay we're talking about this large
screen candle here okay
um so that's the first thing that he
couldn't break up with this son I don't
like that if they if you would have
closed okay the daily candle body above
this one here okay
then that will be a different story for
me because then I can tell you okay then
it's likely that if we manage to close
the next daily candles you know
in this one here then it's very likely
that you see price continue going higher
but it's not the case it couldn't even
break up of this Zone here
okay
um that's what I don't like I don't
think this uh daily candle closes
Wallace in fact I think it's bearish in
my opinion uh we'll see how it plays out
of course you know
um
anything can can play up but I'm just
telling you uh what I think it might be
a different opinion than what you're
getting used to to see in Twitter in the
last 12 hours or so but at least that's
what I think okay uh icr deviation
here okay I said deviation now if we
arrange here below resistance then you
know I'll have it clear we want to go to
the mid range then what I would like to
see is you know another push-up breakup
of the range size don't form an
information a double top because if not
then you're gonna drop so you do need to
see a push here that goes higher and
breaks this High okay then you can hold
here and then that will be my trigger to
go long okay
um that will be a scalp because from
here I'm telling you there is always
resistance resistant resistant
resistance here in all this Zone here in
higher time frame okay
so uh that's what I think be careful of
this deviation here uh be careful with
the daily candle close because I'm
telling you I don't think that's bullish
at all I don't know what you guys think
but I didn't manage to break up of this
Zone
I don't understand how that can be
bullish okay
um so that's what I think guys now
let's go into high block capital and
let's go also to the order book let's
see what is going on okay what is hablo
capital I just went through the open
interest profile through different time
frames and I don't see really any gaps
any open interest gaps uh they were all
filled with the investor-based move okay
uh so that's that's a good thing okay we
don't have imbalances that we can check
then if you go to the liquidation levels
I want to see the Delta how it's looking
I think yesterday was around uh 15
uh billions let me check
right now we sat 15 billion dollars
worth of long liquidation so this is
telling you that the position that it's
a race now it's lungs okay because there
are 15 but cumulative 15 billion dollars
worth of long liquidations okay this
number
15 billions
um
I'll tell you
um I couldn't tell you because it says
15 days when I returned away okay if it
was a 30 40 then I would tell you yeah
this is a good sign that price might
return the right of the chart if you
check this spikes here you got some
interesting specs here at 30 550 and a
bit lower at 29 800 okay
to the website really if you look for
the spikes you know the spikes are not
that big except this one here
data 32k okay but again you know it's
smaller than the ones to the downside so
uh I think just looking at the
liquidation levels we cannot get that
much information but if I have to pick
from here I would say you know because
there are 15 billion dollars worth of
long liquidations and I can see the
biggest despite of liquidations to the
alarm side I would favor lower prices
okay but let's go into the liquidation
hitmap I want to go first to the a one
month time frame
because I want to see that yellow bar
getting or I can say getting removed
from the chart look at that
okay this is what I was telling you guys
remember you know all these past videos
that I was telling you why you know they
said this is Spike here at 31 500 you
know and for two hundred dollars they
didn't come a bit higher and take all
this liquidity and I was telling you
that according to my logic and my
understanding
it was just to you know build more
liquidity in this Zone you can see how
this yellow bar gets bright and bright
and bright and brighter okay that means
that there is more liquidity building up
in that level then yesterday with that
move up they took that liquidity
they reversed okay and now you know
worrying kind of uh no man's land let's
see how evil from here seven days time
frame
let's have a look
okay
uh I can see a lot of things here let me
get this on here
so we took all this liquidity
that was from 31 350. okay you can see
how we took all the liquidity but now if
you check
at least in the seven days time frame
the next yellow bars are to the downside
okay thirty thousand fifty twenty nine
thousand eight hundred again I think we
sold on the liquidation levels I think
it was that level repeated okay so you
know I'm telling you guys be careful
because uh according to high blood
Capital there is quality to the downside
right now according to the Chart maybe
momentum has pivoted so I want to go
back to the chart and have another look
we are back in the charts now if you
allow me let me check the other index
because yesterday they was dropping I
think might be quite important key here
for Bitcoin okay uh okay you can see
here very clear
the white uh rectangle this white box is
uh a resistance Zone and this uh orange
line is a support Zone okay you can see
that I got tested multiple times here
okay and we're talking about the
facility of a three top spot in here
with a deviation below 100 okay uh y
below 100 if this orange unit is at 148
unit because it could deviate here
and there will be a 113 or 120.
and then go up well I'll tell you below
100 because it makes more sense because
it's a better deviation because it
sounds more like 90s you know so anybody
the if this is a deviation I'm not
saying that it is okay but if they form
a deviation here imagine how many people
are right now
short in the dollar Index because it's a
99 no 100 okay
because it has lost
the 100 level okay so uh if it's a
deviation guys this is the perfect
deviation okay uh of course it would
only get confident if we get back inside
this one here above this uh support line
here okay and then in this move up
to watch this resistance
he again uh rejected but if this happens
this move up
to the downside okay uh that's what I
think
um now in the opposite uh case okay if
this is in fact uh a very pattern as
many people are saying because uh this
is a standing triangle that goes uh I
don't know something like this okay so
these are the standing triangle that has
to break to the downside okay uh if
that's the case
and this flag or this isn't triangle
plays out okay
um then what you want to see here for
that Paris move to the downside and go
lower is here
look at all these red candlesia and also
most of them are quite large so the cha
is a bit overextended you know it needs
to retrace to continue going lower now
if that's the case
uh I don't think that we're gonna get uh
if it's bearish okay I don't think it's
gonna get a full retrace towards this
line here and then drop okay if this is
truly berries the most likely thing is
that we see a retrace that it doesn't
get to this Orange Line okay so for
example in this one here uh that's the
128 so for example okay and then from
there drop low okay that's the case if
this is about this if this is bullish of
course you know you have to wait for it
to get back inside the zone and then
here once it is still support you can
long and short Bitcoin very comfortable
okay but that's what I think another
English to see
what it does because it can give you a
clue what Bitcoin might do next
okay now let's get back to bitcoin guys
here
okay
Bitcoin Bitcoin Bitcoin for our time
frame
okay so we were talking about the idea
of the deviation okay then you want to
see
um sideways move in the range highs that
you can short okay that's what I did
yesterday why because here you have in
the one hour time frame
um okay let me tell you you have here
this week you wanna even see a bet in
the Fallout time I'm sorry let me go
back to the photo time frame look at
that week here very clear the week also
this was uh five in the morning for me
so one again here uh we were below the
range highs we had a quick to the
downside so I took a short
from here at 31
414. I think it was so it was basically
in this one here okay the quick has been
at this partially filled so uh it might
at that
let me check the trading sessions okay
because you have here
let's mark Asia London and New York okay
uh so this would be London sorry this
would be AC I mean
okay that move there would be easier now
London if you notice
London is holding
okay it's holding here
and in one and a half New York is gonna
start to place okay so why is likely to
happen it's likely that New York you
know could
half a drop I stopped home here maybe
filled 100 of the week here okay and
then move higher okay
so I'm over like this
for today
um I think it's possible for sure okay
during the New York session so that
would be something like this
let me make it for you
okay
might have to be more tight something
like this okay this move is possible if
you follow the trading systems pattern
this is what you want to see okay you
want to see right at the start of the
New York session
to the downside feel the 50 of the week
okay and then go higher okay that's the
bullish pattern that I can see to the
Forbidden bow in general terms you know
um probably for next week we'll see what
Bitcoin does over the weekend probably
not much but at least that's what I'm
expecting
um usually doesn't do much on the
weekend to be honest but
for next week thinking that
this a deviation
and we cannot get back
above this one here above the range size
okay
it's consolidating here
okay below resistance and in the daily
time frame
we had a fast move up
but we couldn't manage to break Above
This Zone
I can't be bullish here
okay I was born as a 30k I was bullish
here okay why can't people see at the
highs because you know we've had
everything that I was telling you we had
the deviation get back inside the range
consolidate on the resistance so here I
cannot be bullish I cannot tell you that
I that I'm gonna go uh favor in higher
prices again okay because for that I
need to see
um push higher break up of this Zone
here and then consolidate and this would
be my trigger to go long
okay and that would be a scalp why
because you know that we're here there
is a lot of resistance okay so that's
pretty much everything guys
um sorry if you are feeling variables
and this video puts you off of it uh but
understanding to be as neutral and
objective
as possible okay so thank you so much
for watching guys
and I'll see you soon